did they see any of your videos
my dad
my dad
my dad
my parents and my parents didn't mention
the videos for months yeah and we went
out to dinner one night oh no and my dad
looks at me he goes
did you do that like the kardashians on
purpose
and i was like are you [ __ ] kidding
me the guy would leak that on purpose
like with you i don't know
so that's the only time really that
we've talked do you think that they've
watched it no i don't think they're
they're definitely no i don't know like
you want to see what your kid you know
like i had to again i before these like
the bi articles came out i called i knew
it was coming i'm like hey this is
coming out it's all [ __ ] and they
know i mean anybody who knows me knows
so but it's still you know
i don't like it i don't like walking
around with people who don't know me
making assumptions like this guy's a
[ __ ] crazy person yeah yeah yeah that
sucks
and then they have to come up to you and
say like one bite everyone knows the
rules and they're like well which type
of bite yeah yeah
the day my first sex tape
[Laughter]
it's like an hour
that was
the weirdest ever i've nev i couldn't go
a step without somebody like saw tape so
i'd say
like good job this like yeah it was i
mean it's weird because the guy who who
is like a sex tape broker who did the
kardashian tape did paris loves me so
he's now if something comes out he gives
me a heads up he's like just so you know
people are shopping this [ __ ] it's like
thanks man how can they shop it i don't
understand you can't tell you that you
can't you you can leak it like that's
one thing to make clear like we get
taken down right you'll know someone's
making money on it one if yeah because i
i would have to
sign off on that like being made my like
the kardashian thing she had to sign off
on that to or else it couldn't have been
you know used the way it was used so
she's acting like what was me someone
leaked this no [ __ ] way it's not
going to vivid and all those things
unless she signed off because you could
come for them correct yes like no i i
that
ours thank god because i don't give a
[ __ ] about me like honestly yeah but
they're pretty old the sex tapes and i
never was like oh people are going to
want to watch me [ __ ] like that never
crossed my mind and i feel bad for the
girls right like no again if you think
you've gotten better at sex since or
like no
i think that's one of those things like
if i was like
you're like you're [ __ ] that was my
brother
yeah if you're 90 and it's like your
pitchers came back oh i want to throw
99. no you got what you got but it yeah
um no so but i i feel awful again there
are people who are trying to get at me
yeah yeah with no regard for the girl
correct and in the guise of protecting
the girl yeah
right and it's like i don't give a [ __ ]
you're not hurting me like i am
everything's out there i've had the
worst thing said about me people see me
in moments i would prefer not to but i
you're not the damage you're going to do
is actually the girl not the [ __ ]
those tapes didn't really hurt you no
yeah well
um you're just a wild boy you're like yo
big boy
tattoos how many girls from portland dmv
after that right
it's like the old uh one of my favorite
i want a roast is a hasselhoff roast i
forget which comedian said but like how
do you roast a guy whose life is a roast
it's like yeah what are you gonna say
it's all out there yeah like you know
again i would rather not be called like
basically a criminal
rapist which is essentially what bi said
which is insane um
but i guess
for everything that's happened in my
life i i i want it you know i've been
wildly lucky yeah beats working a nine
to five which i was doing but i can see
how
i mean it's crazy the things they've
written about me is as you can see
people like why did you shop about i was
like why does someone call you a rapist
and see how you land
if you're
shut up about it yeah
is there a weird freedom though like
once you get past that like what's the
worst thing that anybody can say is said
and then everybody doesn't believe it
yeah and i'd like to think but it really
[ __ ] still bothers me everyone's like
why you get so mad about it
it just is i mean i think the number one
thing and this is before it came out
that people liked or they're like oh i
like how he does that
uh and again it's not something i knew
was gonna be public
but hbo did like a little inside spirit
yeah i have champagne bottles in my
office oh yeah engraved with people i
hate yeah on a business i just wait
to pop them and then again it's just
that's like me yeah this is before the
bi [ __ ] yeah um so yes some people may
be like oh i can't that's my nature it's
maybe east coast whatever like i hold
long grudges
do you have champagne bottles in your
office right now yeah really is that
what motivates you like yeah
i think i think it is
yeah i think it i i like so you have to
thrive on hate yeah it's like mj [ __ ]
right
[Applause]